Cyprien : Publicités...
Impôts... Faire-part !
Natoo : Attends, mais c'est le mariage d'Inès ça ?!
D'ailleurs euh...
Moi jsais pas...J'ramène Mathieu ou pas?!
Norman : Te plains pas moi j'y vais seul. Ca va être horrible
Tout le monde y va
Pour célébrer l'amour...Moi j'y vais en tant que bon gros célibataire
DES FAMILLES.
Trouve un truc plus triste que ça sérieux.
Cyprien : Mon oncle est mort.
Norman : *rire*
pas mal !
Cyprien : Mon oncle est vraiment mort.
Norman : Ah pardon
Cyprien : Non mais c'était un grand oncle
et puis, j'le connaissais pas vraiment...
Norman : Oh ça va alors
Cyprien : Faut que j'aille à l'enterrement.. C'est important pour ma mère
Natoo : Attends.. euh
J'peux venir avec toi ?
Cyprien : On parle bien d'un enterrement là ...?
Natoo : Non parce que..personne ne meurt dans ma famille !
Cyprien : Quel dommage.
Natoo : Bah oui c'est dommage ! du coup je suis jamais allée à un enterrement !
ce serait l'occasion
Norman: attend c'est pas Ibiza
c'est juste des vieux qui chialent dans une église
Natoo: mais justement faut que je voie ça
allez s'il te plait dit oui ! s'il te plait
Cyprien: d'accord  !
Natoo: Yes!!
trop bien.
Norman: tu n'es pas comme nous Natoo
tu es différente
Cyprien: être adulte, c'est aussi accepter la mort
Natoo: wouah
bah quoi
Cyprien: nan mais tu aurais pu faire un petit effort vestimentaire, je sais pas !
Natoo: bah tu m'as pas dit qu'il y avait un dress code
et puis ce n'était pas marqué sur le flyer donc euh!
Maman de Cyprien : bonjour mon chéri. Cyprien : ah maman ça va ?
Maman de Cyprien : oui
Cyprien: Maman je te présente...
Maman: oh!!!! oh je vous rencontre enfin !
Natoo: moi aussi
Maman: oh vous etes encore plus belle que je le pensais
Natoo: merci
Maman: Martine la maman de cyprien
Natoo: enchantée, Nathalie
Martine: Nathalie ?
mais c'etait pas Laurie son nom à ta femme
Cyprien: Alors Laurie Déjà c'est pas ma femme c'est ma petite amie
elle a pas pu venir parce qu'elle travaille
et je suis avec Nathalie une amie
Martine: Je suis désolée
vous vous rendez compte ça fait 7 ans qu'il est avec sa cherie
il me l'a jamais presentée !
Natoo: sérieux ?
Cyprien: Nan mais c'est un hasard ça va !
Martine: c'est qu'on va finir par croire qu'il l'a inventée !
Oh c'est comme Tonton Daniel là,
on disait qu'il avait des femmes en veux tu en voilà!
Penses tu !
il etait tout seul
Cyprien: Très bien, bon je vais vous laisser discuter entre vous hein, entre filles
moi je... je fais un tour
Natoo: Bon comment ça se passe,
y'a un buffet ? des petits fours ?
J'ai un peu.. la dalle là
*musique d'église*
Prêtre: Bonjour mon fils
Cyprien: Mon père
Prêtre: sache que je suis de tout coeur avec toi
Cyprien: Merci
Prêtre: Bon pour l'ordre j'ai d'abord pensé à faire passer ta grand-mère,
ensuite la chanson de ton oncle et pour finir, toi et ton discours
Cyprien: Mon discours?
Grand-mère: Daniel, ce n'est pas un au revoir, c'est un... à bientôt
et même à... à très bientôt
Natoo: Mais c'est super triste les enterrements en fait...
Cyprien: Bah oui...
Prêtre: C'était très émouvant, merci pour tout ça Denise
Avant d'écouter le petit neveu de Daniel Cyprien Jean Iov
Nous allons tous ensemble écouter
Cyprien: Cyprien?
Martine: Bah oui tu portes le deuxième prénom de ton oncle
Cyprien: Tu me l'as jamais dit!
Martine: Bah tu me l'as jamais demandé
Prêtre: Cette chanson sur laquelle Daniel a voulu nous dire au revoir c'est "End of the line"
du groupe, Wadows Ford
*musique End of the line"
Cyprien: ouais mmh
Bah heu, Daniel!
mmh Tonton Daniel, comme je l'appelais parce que c'est... parce que c'est mon tonton
Non c'est pas mon tonton, c'est le tonton de ma mère
Bref mmh, Tonton Daniel
heuuuu *bruit d'appareil photo*
Tuuuu *rire gêné*
j'oublierai jamais quand tu...
Tu tu tu; j'oublierai que tu te toi, déjà
J'oublierai jamais toi
Bon heu désolé en fait, j'avoue je connais pas grand chose sur Tonton Daniel
Si quelqu'un veut faire un discours sur Tonton Daniel, rappeler quelques souvenirs
Bah il peut plutôt prendre ma place
je suis vraiment désolé hein
D'accord en fait à part Mamie y'a personne qui peut parler de Tonton Daniel et faire un discours?
Grand-mère: Et encore j'ai recopier le discours que j'ai fait pour le décès de ma soeur
Cyprien: bon
ok...
Tonton Daniel, t'étais quelqu'un de très secret, un peu comme nous tous dans cette famille, moi compris hein!
Je sais pas si c'est de la pudeur ou de la lâcheté, un petit peu des deux j'imagine
En tout cas j'ai appris plein de choses sur toi aujourd'hui, beaucoup plus qu'en 27 ans
J'ai appris que je m'appelais Cyprien en partie grâce à toi
J'ai appris que tu écoutais Windows Ford, un de mes groupes préférés aussi
Je me disais que... on se connaissait pas très bien et que c'était pas grave
Et en fait aujourd'hui je me dis que bah , c'est un peu dommage
On se serait bien entendu je pense
Au revoir Tonton Daniel
Natoo: Whouuu bravo
Natoo applaudit
*cloches d'église*
*Cloche d'église*
Natoo: Eh vous pensez que je peux conduire le mini-van là?
Cyprien: Corbillard, évite...
*Cloche d'église*
Maman : C'était très bien Cyp', alors, on te revoit quand ? Pas avant Noël j'imagine?
Cyprien: Bah en fait je me disais comme Laurie la semaine prochaine elle... Elle travaille pas
donc heu si tu passes chez moi, je...
*Cloche d'église*
Maman : tu veux me la présenter?
Cyprien: non mais je dis ça fin je veux pas...
*Cloche d'église*
Martine: ah non non non, si si, ça me ferait très plaisir Cyprien
Natoo: c'était trop bien!
Natoo: j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait un DJ à mon enterrement
Cyprien: ouais ce serait une bonne idée ouais
Natoo: et puis alors plein de bougies comme ça parce que c'est trop beau
Cyprien: non mais Nat', il faut les laisser les bougies, là
Natoo: n'importe quoi, je l'ai payée je la prends, quoi.
*Musique d'outro*
Sous-titres : JimmyTheTest, Light, Meemy 04, Dan G, Titiwaliii ! et Elyji